on this monday night racing to rescue
afghans what canadian special forces are
now doing and the taliban's warning if
evacuations continue beyond august 31st
plus powerful words from an afghan
filmmaker they didn't have to sell us
out to the terrorists can you believe
that a terrorist group can change
overnight the rise of the fourth wave
it's a virus it does not care how tired
we are grim predictions about the autumn
deja vu on the campaign the billions the
liberals are again promising to boost
health care plus keep calm and carry on
a royal tradition back at buckingham
palace
global national with donna friesen
those desperate to escape are not giving
up hope there is still a crush of people
outside kabul's airport waiting for
hours hoping they'll be allowed on board
one of the evacuation flights more
planes are coming and going
but the window is closing august 31st is
the withdrawal date the u.s and the
taliban agreed to just eight days to get
tens of thousands of people out it's
likely not everyone who wants to leave
will make it out by then
good evening and thanks for joining us
pressure is mounting on u.s president
joe biden to extend that deadline urgent
talks will take place tomorrow g7
leaders led by britain's prime minister
will discuss the evacuation process
biden has said he is considering
extending the mission but the taliban is
not
in an interview with sky news a taliban
spokesperson called the august 31st
deadline a red line
president biden
announced
this agreement that until uh 31st of
august they would withdraw all their
military forces
so if they extend it that means they are
extending occupation so it will
provoke reaction
with the clock ticking canada's defense
department says special forces are now
on the ground in kabul going outside the
airport compound to try to reach
canadians and eligible afghans in those
crowds mike armstrong has our top story
tonight
it is a desperate situation more and
more desperate by the hour crowds that
were lucky enough to make it through
taliban checkpoints to reach kabul
airport stand in the heat for hours some
up to their knees in dirty water waiting
in a ditch they waive passports and
documents
for those who've turned up told they'd
be going to canada they were instructed
to wear red to stand out and be spotted
by canadian soldiers we see you
keep waving
for the first time ottawa is confirming
canadian soldiers deployed to the kabul
airport are also working outside an
official says canadian special forces
have been going out into the city to
help get people to the airport that
official also confirms there have been
four canadian flights since the airport
reopened august 19th transporting a
total of just over 850 people canada is
one of 13 countries taking part in the
airbridge operation out of afghanistan
the official says canada has one spot
for a plane reserved each day for as
long as the american-led operation runs
i'm exhausted from the amount of
messaging i'm putting out there cyr
karimi is trying to get his mother out
of kabul the toronto woman went back to
visit family in june against the urging
of her son now she's stuck karimi says
he spent days trying to get help from
canadian officials but has only gotten
automated email responses for now he
says her mood seems to be okay she's
very optimistic she's told me to like
hey stay calm but i'm worried that she's
just doing that because she's a mother
and she knows if she's not calm then i'm
not going to be calm
canadian officials say taliban
checkpoints around the airport are
choking access
there's also increasing violence there
was another gun battle at one point
monday about 20 people have been killed
in recent days and the chaos around the
airport
a canadian veterans group that's been
working to get interpreters and other
afghans out says it got 13 families to
the airport monday that's about 60
people who have been approved to travel
to canada it is progress but it's slow
and time is running out
mike armstrong global news
a little later i speak to an afghan
filmmaker who says the hopes and dreams
of an entire generation are being lost
but first the pandemic the bc government
is launching a kind of vaccine passport
british columbians will soon be required
to provide proof of vaccination to go to
many non-essential indoor events
including concerts sports movies
restaurants nightclubs and casinos
as of september 13th you will need to
have at least one dose of vaccine to
enter these settings and by october 24th
entry to these settings will require
people age 12 and
older to be fully vaccinated at least
seven days after receiving both doses
the province hopes the new system will
help reduce transmissions and ensure
businesses can remain open in the fall
it plans to release more information on
the bc vaccine card early next month
the more contagious delta variant is now
dominant in many places and it could
drive case counts higher than ever this
fall vaccines mean far fewer people will
get sick and die but as jaime morocco
reports hospitals are still bracing to
be
overwhelmed low on doctors and nurses
alberta health services is invoking
emergency staffing measures as the
colbit numbers rise and as the
hospitalization numbers rise that's
going to cause more stress at an already
stressed
and not fully operating system right now
and health experts there say coveted
cases could skyrocket to 5 000 a day
shasma methane says she's scared for
fall with alberta in particular because
there are really no public health
measures or any sort of meaningful
public health measures remaining
we're seeing the delta spreading very
rapidly in bc when cases took off in
kelowna the province's top doctor
brought back a mask mandate for the
interior it does seem that the growth in
interior health is moderated still
modeling there shows without
intervention daily cases will rise into
the thousands the virus does not care
what you and i think it does not care
how tired we are of dealing with this
alison mcgear anticipates a delta driven
spike will take ontario to nearly 7 000
daily cases by thanksgiving if we don't
do something about the increasing number
of cases
we're going to push our health care
system over the limited game and many
people are going to die a terrifying
trajectory says dr mathani as many
unvaccinated children head back into
schools young children are affected more
with the delta variant it's more
virulent it's more transmissible and
it's having more severe outcomes experts
say provinces should act now requiring
smaller class sizes mass mandates
physical distancing guidelines and
vaccination for those who are eligible
to prevent the icus from getting
overwhelmed
currently 75 percent of eligible
canadians have been fully vaccinated
shy of the government's 83 percent
summer target donna jamie morocco in
toronto thanks health care is always a
big concern for canadians today liberal
leader justin trudeau promised to spend
billions to hire new family doctors and
nurse practitioners though it's not the
federal government who actually hires
them there is a massive shortage about 5
million canadians don't have access to a
primary health care provider mercedes
stephenson is traveling with the liberal
campaign tonight mercedes
donna the liberals are campaigning
heavily on health care here in atlantic
canada where it is a huge political
issue in fact last week's nova scotia
election was fought and may have been
won on it here in newfoundland and
labrador nearly 90 thousand people are
without a family doctor and if the
liberals hope to get a majority they
need to win over atlantic canadians on
issues like this
on monday in halifax liberal leader
justin trudeau promised six billion
dollars to reduce healthcare wait times
and another three billion dollars to
hire 7500
and nurses this is our moment to rebuild
a health care system that works for all
canadians if that sounds familiar it's
because he made a similar promise in the
2019 campaign that every canadian would
have a family doctor
two years later that hasn't happened
these are kind of empty promises
i i mean they have to attach the money
to actual teeth there have to be strings
attached to say to get the money the
provinces have to do xyz and there needs
to be leadership and that's really
what's missing here the federal
government doesn't hire doctors that's
the province's job and the premiers have
been clear about what they want
making their demands on ottawa just
before the last federal budget when
health matters more than ever the
liberals have promised an increase to
health transfers after the pandemic but
have not said how much they would spend
only that the federal government
supported the provinces during the
pandemic the ndp said they would
increase health care spending but
without details on where or how
the conservatives are the only party to
lay out their health care platform so
far with aaron o'toole campaigning on an
increase to health transfers from three
percent to six percent which works out
to about sixty billion dollars i 100
percent support our public
and universal health care system in fact
it's been the backbone we've relied on
through the pandemic mercedes stephenson
global news st johns
there is a bit of a kerfuffle going on
over a campaign video the liberals
released twitter flagged it as
manipulated media it shows conservative
leader aaron o'toole expressing support
for a private for-profit health care
system but a key part of his message was
edited out by the liberals michael
couture explains what happened and the
fallout
we can't have just one old model the
year-old video seems to show
conservative leader aaron o'toole
speaking in favor of two-tier health
care it was tweeted by deputy prime
minister christopher freeland but
twitter quickly slapped this label on it
flagging it as manipulated media
canadians deserve better than that
monday o'toole said he 100 percent
supports canada's public universal
system and he slammed the liberals for
the smear misleading people importing
american style media manipulation to our
campaign with within the first 10 days
leader justin trudeau's defense of the
edited video was to point people to the
unedited version in the middle of a
pandemic
aaron o'toole came out
unequivocally in support of private
health care
in terms of for-profit health care now
it's not that clear when you watch the
full version because in one breath
o'toole says universal access is
paramount and in another i actually
praised what brad wall did with respect
to diagnostic imaging because he's
actually making sure that wait times for
everyone go down ndp leader jagmeet
singh says the campaign is entering
dangerous territory it is really
disconcerting though that
the current party in power is engaging
in exactly what we need to be ending
this former liberal staffer and current
communications expert says twitter was
overzealous in labeling the tweet
manipulated the minister was only taking
a direct quote and putting it out there
in a short format which is what you need
for online the tories don't see it that
way and the party is asking for an
investigation to see if the liberals
violated the canada elections act by
intentionally altering the video
donna all right michael couture thanks
elsewhere on the campaign trail ndp
leader jug meat singh made a commitment
to clean up the environment pledging to
reallocate subsidies for oil and gas
companies if he's elected
all subsidies new democrats believe in
ending fossil fuel subsidies period
it's been going on for too long the ndp
leader says he will redirect the
subsidies to renewables to create jobs
in the clean energy sector
the pfizer biontech shock finally fully
approved in the u.s coming up what it
could do for that country's stalled
vaccination rate
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
talk about a royal comeback at
buckingham palace the changing of the
guard ceremony is back always a crowd
pleaser the coldstream guards have been
on hiatus since the start of the
pandemic the time-honored tradition is
the official handover of responsibility
for protecting the palace
the u.s has finally granted full
approval to the pfizer biontech vaccine
millions of americans have already
received it but until now it's only had
emergency use authorization this not
only opens the door for more vaccine
mandates in the u.s it could win over
some vaccine skeptics at a time when the
virus is surging jackson proskow
explains the context
deep in the throes of another covid
surge comes a shot of confidence in the
vaccines those who've been waiting for
full approval should go get your shot
now using data from forty four thousand
clinical trial participants the fda has
given the pfizer biontech vaccine full
approval
92 million americans are already fully
vaccinated with pfizer but there are
still plenty of skeptics
where does full fda approval fit on the
spectrum of helping convince people to
get vaccinated unfortunately i think
full fda approval does not fit high on
the spectrum it for individuals i think
it does fit high on the spectrum for
large organizations employers
states cities and local jurisdictions to
put in a mandate within minutes of the
approval new york city announced it
would require all teachers and school
support staff to get the jab the
pentagon confirmed a mandate for all
members of the u.s military these
efforts ensure the safety of our service
members
it comes at a critical juncture in the
pandemic as cases and deaths surge again
doctors in florida say they're at the
breaking point the heartbreak now is
we're not just going into work and
working long hours but we're seeing
people who don't need to be in the
hospital who are healthy who are young
through mandate or motivation fda
approval will lead millions more to get
vaccinated while raising questions about
when vaccine coverage will be expanded i
think what people are focusing on is
when are children between the ages of 5
and 12 gonna be vaccinated
there's no timeline for approval in
young children even as they head back to
school
other vaccines like modernis are still
under fda review
fda approval may help shake the
perception these shots are experimental
or untested at a time when they may be
more important than ever
jackson proskow global news washington
[Music]
tennessee in turmoil ahead record
rainfall turns deadly in the southern
state
tropical storm ahri is slamming the
northeast united states pounding several
states across the region with heavy rain
and high winds in new jersey hundreds
either fled their homes or had to be
rescued after the storm triggered flash
floods
the remnant of re is now heading into
atlantic canada as a weaker tropical
depression heavy rain will soak parts of
the maritimes until wednesday but no
strong winds are expected
and a severe storm also hit central
tennessee record-breaking rain triggered
flash flooding turning streets into
torrance and causing widespread
destruction and death at least 22 people
have been killed there dozens more are
missing
what's being lost as the taliban take
over i speak with an afghan filmmaker
next
that's a clip from a film written and
directed by afghan filmmaker diana sakeb
jamal she lives in kabul making films
she hopes will inspire and influence
people
she was in canada visiting family when
the pandemic hit and that prolonged her
stay here and now she's watching events
unfold at home and feeling sick with
grief
diana sakeb jamal is with me now from
toronto diana thanks for taking the time
to speak with us how are you doing what
are you thinking and feeling as you
watch events unfold in your home country
well
not good
i wake up every day
with so much pain in my heart
i feel i can't breathe
i feel my heart is pounding
and then i remember what happened to my
country
what happened to my city
and to my people
i remember that
we have been sold out to the terrorists
we lost our lives
to build that country from zero from the
ground
and now we lost everything overnight
after 20 years we don't deserve this
i'm sorry
but afghanistan don't deserve this we're
not belong to terrorists
after or don't apologize don't apologize
for your for your emotion don't
apologize
it's it's justified and and the world is
watching this and and
so much of the world feeling the pain of
the afghan people
i wonder
as you see these tens of thousands of
people rush to the airport
do you think a generation of afghans is
going to have to bury their dreams and
aspirations
yes
we all did the day that kabul falls
we did
i'm asking the president of united
states i'm asking the world leaders can
you sleep at night
and shame on you if you can because we
can't
and you try to put the blame on us you
try to tell us that we are to blame
is this all our fault no it isn't and
i'm so sorry for people who believe you
no this is not my fight you
know i was working in afghanistan for
over a decade
spending my own money taking a high risk
working so hard
to bring light and hope to my country to
my beloved afghanistan
to give the next generation of
afghanistan
hope and a smile using my filmmaking
tools
to give
the people of afghanistan a smile
build a cinema
for
for small kids
why you did this to us
diana you've heard the taliban promising
peace order and an amnesty for everyone
taliban leaders claiming no one will be
harmed that they're different from the
taliban 20 years ago do you have any
faith in that
can you believe that a terrorist group
can change overnight
no sane person will believe that
no
they haven't changed
we know them
this time yeah they changed because they
need international recognition
that's why they start playing nice
no they haven't changed
do you think you will
ever go back to afghanistan
yes i do
i have my return to get back to kabul
for september
i'm going to keep that
i'm a filmmaker
i have to go back
it's my home
diana thank you so much for taking the
time to talk to us we'll check in with
you again thank you very much
for speaking with me
sure thank you
thank you okay take care
and you can watch the full interview on
our website after we recorded it diana
apologized to me for being so emotional
she had been determined
not to cry
she's part of a generation of girls and
women who believed they could go to
school go to work and live with agency
in afghanistan and though thousands are
fleeing she is determined that at some
point she'll go back
because she says that's where her heart
is
thanks for watching
[Music]
you